I love video games I don't have the time
to play them all the time but when I do
I love the immersive world of video
games it's like being in your own movie
and you're the director Assassin's Creed
is really cool because it takes the best
of the worlds out loud I love action I
love history and so when you get a
chance to go back in time and actually
explore these worlds it's pretty amazing
Straight Outta Compton was a film that
was on my radar and I thought about you
know maybe Gary would be interested in
telling an old-school period piece
through a West Coast lens the first day
I met with Colin man it felt like a
bunch of friends getting together and
said wouldn't it be cool if we did this
wouldn't we cool we did this and we met
for hours and we went over the
storyboards and we went over the script
talked about what we wanted we talked
about the feel and the look and the
emotion and what imagery would give you
that gangster kind of thing and then pop
took it and blew it out yeah I'm a huge
fan of Assassin's Creed graphically you
know as an artist I've always been drawn
to games the amount of detail that the
developers put into the game the color
palettes I mean so rich so vibrant
you know everything about the graphics
of the game has been it's just
phenomenal
pop not only took what we were thinking
but he improved upon it and it just
floored me one of the things I've loved
about Gary's work has always been the
way he does action sequences the things
that we're doing here is really allowed
me to play off of my strengths as a you
know energetic comic-book artist
we're good mark for about a year now and
you have a if we have a synergy so
whenever I'm doing shots that calls for
a specific mood I can always rely on the
fact that mark roll you know hit it on
the on the on the head every time it's
good to have someone who you collaborate
with that you can trust you know is it
gonna be there and you know do what he
needs to do and then you can elaborate
on what he's put down on paper and bring
it to life and you just add your you
don't touch to it one of the opening
shots where we finally reveal Jacob and
II it's the first time we really see
Jacob and his face and his detail
you know I comment more myself into it
and I'm really happy with the way it
turned out then you take the 3d
animation and give it that depth and now
you feel like you're in a world add
sound and sound effects and it feels
like a movie the whole story in the
editing process really revolves around
the voice I find and if you have a
really good actor that gives a really
good performance it makes our job easier
a man who stole what he wanted from
those who had nothing but there was one
thing he would never receive mercy
having been a huge fan of you know
Assassin's Creed way from the beginning
I'm I've always wanted to be a part of
the mythos it's been a really exciting
project for me work on to read about is
one thing but be transported and
immersed in this era the Industrial
Revolution 1868 with these characters
and then have fun with a little bit of
gangsterism that is the Gallifrey
Assassin's Creed syndicate
you